te le dit tony tu vas être champion du
monde j'en suis sûr et quand tu seras
champion du monde c'est pas une fête
qu'on va faire faire les frères mais
côtoie d'un pendant une semaine si elle
est on va faire c'est fini vous ne voyez
plus à jour que c'est un de mes rêves
que tony conte accord comme un coq tu
vas pas un championnat du monde tu
penses quoi trois ans on avait dit ça on
avait 5 ans quand je crois j'ai commencé
mais en faisant trois ans on va faire
moins elle prochaine ah ouais ça marche
pas tu es sur les prochaines pas libre à
venir calme-toi de l'atonie ton trader
calme-toi tony c'est parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui te critike élan et
après le combat de samedi soir parce que
c'est que si elle est au destin un
immense champion il ya plein de gens qui
te critiquer ça s'est un peu calmé là
que tu lis parce que qu'est ce tu dis à
ces gens là après les critiques ça fait
partie du ca sur ces c'est comme ça
seulement moi j'ai juste demandé un peu
de temps
c'est forcément surpasse pro ben t'as
besoin de monter dans le classement je
peux pas aller défier en tenue je serai
pas boxer a bien sûr dans le top 10 par
un top 5 il champion du monde à rennes
mais ces surcoûts faut que je puisse
monter au classement pour prétendre à
mieux
et voilà c'était la première fois que je
boxais pas cyril était comme quatre fois
champion de france professionnel c'est
un grand boxeur à c'est pas rien c'est
un surmoi j'adore ce boxeur vraiment et
est donc là le prochain combat s'avère
contre le champion de france qui a battu
cyril et au nez il ya quelques mois
c'est sûr il a dit oui ou pas parce que
tu as tu lui as tu lui a proposé tout au
combat causé samedi
est ce qu'elle a dit oui c'est bon pas
encore prêt et tu as dit que tu es là
non c'est un énorme truc c'est quoi
l'histoire annonce à un gros combat
après après le printemps c'est quoi non
mais on va dire qu'on a fait cette
annonce maintenant du coup on retiendra
plus on va dire que l'on sait déjà qu'il
tirait alors que ce sera contre rafa ça
va être un gros combat contre la france
a commencé il ya une ceinture en jeu
cela sera la première b mais si tu
gagnes va imaginons que je gagne pas
déjà le combat d'après ouais c'est
contre eux il ya un américain en
américains n'ont cessé pour un titre en
jeu peut-être peut-être genre est un
autre championnat d'europe leader
boehner
quel magazine so foot camille messi qui
met des triplets le bayern qui fait un
titre tony yoka qui bastonne un vigile
de supermarché et tous qui marque des
buts de fouine ce film du week-end tu le
connais déjà par coeur et tony vous avez
leur avait répondu va falloir rester sur
le foot ou alors se renseigner un peu
mieux un boxeur quatre fois champion de
france professionnel que vous comparez à
un vigile aucun respect et c'est vrai
que cyril et au nez c'est un très grand
boxeur et c'est un manque de respect
pour lui tu réponds toujours j'ai vu tu
répondais je réponds quand quant à quand
c'est nécessaire
là je trouve que quand c'est juste des
détracteurs je laisse parler mais là
c'est un magazine e
c'est certain que ça va libérer ce n'est
pas forcément pour moi mais pour cyril
exactement sur quelle série moi c'est ça
le truc à une petite guéguerre un truc
avec les avec l'antidopage que tu t'es
pas présenter aux contrôles
c'est ce que tu as à ckoi en fait
l'histoire il ya eu beaucoup de remixes
et forcément les téléspectateurs sont
pas forcément au courant de ce qui s'est
vraiment passé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je me suis pas
présenté au japon est au rendez vous
avec des contrôles inopinés
d'accord ils viennent quand ils veulent
et tous les jours tu vas dire août est
en route et tous les jours tous les
jours et donc on l'a fait on n'a fait
heureusement qu'ils contrôlent pas jean
michel meyer mail et tous les jours dans
l'année
alors merci donc on l'a fait avant les
jeux j'ai vu un problème avant les jeux
c'était que il s'ennuie ou contre le 16
mai le lendemain forcément j'ai changé
mon après celui que j'étais en france
bien sûr c'est rentré entre temps était
dans l'avion ils sont passés quand même
temps l'avion abbas a fait le show c'est
voilà c'est ça c'est compliqué après les
jeux mois on a pris six sept mois de
vacances avec estelle lgt pas du tout
sur ma carrière sportive après donc fait
voulait profiter de ta femme et la
société un petit bébé maintenant qu'on
embrasse très très fort l e petit de
tony hawk a sur la tête de ma mère le
fils de tony déjà sur la sur ma vie je
pense qu'il défonce maxim guérin
la colle à la vue voix sur la glande
mammaire lui - il fait de m il a
lui-même fait 13 ou 14 qui lui servent
et man alors j'achète du deux ans non
mais c'est pas joli dernière s'est vue
trop cliché de fursac en train de
chercher d'accord elle était chercher
mon rayon et tony t'aurais fait quoi
concevoir style pas fait de boxe tu
aurais tu es bon quoi je voulais je
voulais faire du basket
normal ce qui est pas si sûr taille pas
faire je fais grand jeu vous la met à ne
pas faire de la course automobile a été
passée de la voiture était comme
sincérité patriotards elle va vous avec
les pieds